foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
scattering microcoscopy label free
Imaging approaches I'm Susie Valdez of
lab roots and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by Teledyne photometrics
to learn more visit them at
photometrics.com now we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during this
presentation to do so simply type them
in to the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
I'd like to welcome now our speakers
first Professor Philip kukura professor
of chemistry and the Department of
Chemistry at University of Oxford Dr
Francisco Arena post-doctoral researcher
in The Institute of Applied Optics and
biophysics at University of yena Dr
Philip Ellen product manager at Teledyne
photometrics and Dr Matthew kosedan
content manager at Teledyne photometrics
welcome to all of you speakers you may
now begin your presentation
and welcome to another tele9
photometrics webinar
my name is Dr Matthew kozidan and I'll
be your host for this webinar all about
scattering microscopy label-free Imaging
approaches
firstly a bit about us at
telephotometrics
we design and manufacture high-end
cameras for demanding quantitative
research in the life sciences and
physical sciences
we're a market leader for scientific
CMOS technology and have over 40 years
of experience with the Imaging industry
becoming part of the turbine group in
but I'm not the only speaker on this
webinar I've also invited product
manager Dr Phil Allen for a product
update as well as two guest speakers who
are experts in the field of scattering
microscopy namely Dr Francesco Reyna
from the University of yena
and Professor Philip kakura of the
University of Oxford
I will firstly be giving an introduction
to scattering microscopy and the
techniques and we'll then pass over to
our guest speakers for a more detailed
look into this fascinating field of
Imaging
scattering microscopy techniques present
an alternative to fluorescent Imaging
but why is this alternative necessary
the detection and tracking of single
particles is highly valuable for
scientific research particularly in the
study of the cell membrane or of
interactions between proteins other
proteins and surfaces
in fluorescence microscopy these samples
can be studied with the attachment of a
fluorescent probe or label in order to
provide contrast and localize these
substances which can then be imaged at
high speed with a scientific camera in
order to characterize and track these
samples
these fluorescence techniques are highly
popular for this format of single
molecule research
however there are limitations
labeling can be non-specific or
incomplete the rates of emission from a
label can be quite low or irregular
and these fluorescent probes can be
subject to photochemical effects such as
quenching blinking and even
phototoxicity
in addition if there are multiple
samples to label it is important to use
labels that are separate enough in
wavelength to not overlap which can lead
to a crowded Imaging Spectrum if many
samples need to be imaged which cameras
often bleed through and the use of
time-consuming multi-channel Imaging
these drawbacks could be avoided by
doing away with the fluorescence label
entirely an approach known as label-free
Imaging
labor-free Imaging is possible due to
the optical process known as scattering
while not all samples can be
successfully fluorescent
every substance can scatter light in
some format
using scattering would avoid the
drawbacks of fluorescence and is a near
instantaneous process
by Imaging light scattered from the
sample instead of fluorescence
excitation the drawbacks of fluorescent
labeling are avoided
Imaging using these scattering
techniques can be referred to as
scattering microscopy
these techniques are typically label
free
this means that you avoid the pitfalls
of labeling
and these techniques need to be able to
detect weak signal from a particle
against a very large Imaging background
you need contrast in order to see the
small particles you're Imaging as seen
from the figure in addition the tracking
is permanent the sample is always
scattering light you can track it for as
long as you need to essentially which
avoids the drawback of something like
bleaching
or quenching from fluorescence where
there's a time limit on how long you can
detect your particle for
and in terms of the resolution and speed
these techniques have nanoscale spatial
resolution in 3D and micro scale
temporal resolution so you can capture
fast Dynamic events
vital to certain scattering microscopy
techniques is the optical process known
as interference
the scattered light can be in Phase or
outer phase with the illumination which
can lead to constructive or destructive
interference respectively
with coherent scattering you can achieve
constructive interference which would
boost the signal
and the amplitude of low scattering
signals from small particles allowing
for easier detection with a sensitive
scientific camera there are groups of
Imaging techniques that rely on this
kind of interference known as
interferometric microscopy
with the most well-known being
interferometric scattering or ice cap
microscopy
in ice cap microscopy
the sample is illuminated and scatters
light
we can see here a comparison between
bright field Imaging and ice-scat
imaging
in bright field Imaging the reference
light travels through the sample and
interferes with scattered light in ice
cap the scattered light interferes with
a reference light field at a surface so
weak scattered light
interferes with a stronger reference
light field this constructive
interference allows for a stronger
signal which is then detected with a
camera
here we can see the flexibility of ice
scat
iscat can be used in both reflection and
transmission approaches as well as wide
field or confocal setups
iscat has also successfully been used in
combination with other techniques such
as turf or total internal reflection
fluorescence microscopy
ice cap microscopy has a very high
detection sensitivity and signal to
noise ratio even at very high speeds
this makes it well suited for Imaging
protein motility in live cells
especially interactions between these
proteins and the cell membrane
here we have some examples of ice cap
microscopy being used on live samples
in the first image a we have gold
labeled myosin
proteins moving along acting filaments
we have microtubules being driven by
kinesin Motors lipid microdomains and
formation of a supported lipid bilayer
this is all captured using scattering
microscopy techniques while icecat can
be done label free as we can see from
image a you can also do iscat with
labels the labels in this case are high
scattering particles such as gold
nanoparticles
when using these techniques it's also
important to consider the image
background which is often the same
wavelength as the signal and can change
over time
you can also remove it using certain
algorithms or by recognizing label
symmetry but the background can also be
used to gather more information from
your sample such as how the sample is
moving or drifting in 3D space
there are also other scattering
microscopy techniques similar to iscat
namely dark field microscopy and
coherent bright field or Cobra
microscopy
in iska the reference field corresponds
to the reflected light at an interface
and cobre it's quite similar to icecat
but the transmitted light is used as the
reference field so both light fields are
in the same plane
and in dark field there's no
interference at all you simply detect
the scattered light from your sample
another exciting technique in this field
is Mass photometry
there are also other scattering
microscopy techniques similar to icecat
namely dark field microscopy and
coherent bright field or cobrae
microscopy
in ice skirt the reference field
corresponds to the reflected light at an
interface
in Cobra
it's quite similar to iscat but the
transmitted light is used as the
reference field so both light fields are
in the same plane
and a dark field there's no interference
at all you simply detect the scattered
light from your sample
these different available techniques
allow for flexible experimental and
Optical design depending on the samples
you want to image and your signal level
another exciting technique in this field
is Mass photometry
the light scattered from a sample can be
used to measure its mass hence why the
technique is known as mass photometry
so a single molecule on a Surface will
scatter light proportional to its own
Mass
and this sample signal will then
interfere with light scattered from the
surface itself
so the light from the sample will
interfere with the light from the
surface and the intensity of this light
can be used to calculate the true
molecular mass of each particle on the
surface
this technique was developed by
Professor Philip kakura at the
University of Oxford and I think we'll
agree he would be the best person to
further explain this technique and its
applications
so without further Ado let's hear from
our two Imaging experts and guest
speakers Professor Philip kakura and Dr
Francesco Reyna
so I'm Frances Karina I'm a postdoctoral
researcher at the live needs ibst in the
biophysical Imaging group led by
Professor Christina aguiling and my main
research focus is into single particle
tracking and in particular single
particle tracking on living samples such
as cell lines model cell lines and
trying to understand the how the
Dynamics of particles or molecules on on
the plasma membrane affects the
physiological function of the cells
itself my name is
um professor of chemistry at the
University of Oxford
I do mostly research but also teach and
my research has really has completely
transitioned or focuses entirely on
technology that we call Mass photometry
which essentially is using microscopes
in slightly unusual ways not so much
focusing on taking images and analyzing
these images and learning
from these images or movies but much
more to use the information to provide
you know biophysical uh or bioanalytical
characterization of of fire molecules
essentially
you know if you think about
light microscopy is a thing you know go
all the way back to you know 400 years
ago
um
it's a relatively simple idea right you
shine light on stuff and then you have a
look I mean that's how that's how
everything works right that's how we see
each other because light bounces off my
head goes to the camera
Etc and then you know the microscopy
context you essentially do the same
thing that we do except that you you
know use Optics in order to magnify your
image so you're looking at smaller and
smaller features
so the concept of scattering is kind of
you know fundamental to the interaction
of lightweight matter
as long as I have slightly different
Optical properties that are my
environment I will scatter light right
so because I'm not out of air you can
see me
accepting that
um
the real challenge is you know you want
to see smaller and smaller smaller
things and the smaller they get
the weaker the interaction is going to
be with the light and therefore you know
it's going to become more difficult to
see
and so over the last
100 years certainly people have been
working on developing methods to try and
isolate
um
smaller and smaller signal the idea
being you know if you can if you can
separate the signal from the background
um the better you can do that the
smaller an object you could
and there's various implementations of
that I mean the kind of original one if
you like probably was called Dark field
microscopy
and it's a relatively simple idea right
if you think about it let's say you have
your object let's say you could hold
your object in in free space
uh if you shine a laser beam on it some
of the light will get scattered if you
look at 90 degrees
uh to the object the only light you will
see is the light that is scattered by
the object
so that's dark field because the
illumination field disappears
and in fact that works so well uh that
you can see you know single atoms with
your eye
if you're if you're an atom suspended in
vacuum you're trying to laser but you
want to look at 90 degrees you can
actually see it with your eye so I guess
what that tells you is that in principle
this concept of Shining Light on stuff
and look at light that
bounces off of it can be exceptionally
sensitive
um but the problem always is suppressing
the background
right and so the reason why you can see
a single atom is because it's a vacuum
there's nothing else that scatters light
so the only way the light's going to hit
your eye is if there is an atom that
scatters it towards you
um
and that becomes more challenging if
you're looking at the condensed phase
right if you're looking at actually
matter
because there's lots of stuff that can
scatter like produce
produce signal
so the different forms are you know the
dark field that I mentioned that's much
more similar to fluorescence so you're
trying to detect a very small signal and
again it's essentially hopefully zero
background
and then there's lots of interferometric
techniques where
you more or less mix the scattered light
with the light that you use for
illumination
and you know I'm not going to talk you
through the
Oodles of variations of this right the
holography would be an example of it uh
people have done a transmission reflect
you know every way you can imagine
both have their advantages and
disadvantages it really depends on what
you're after
um but I would say the interferometric
techniques
are quite different in terms of the
experimental requirements uh to the dark
field the dog field is more like
fluorescence because a small signal on
top of zero background interferometric
is a slightly different Beast
because you're trying to detect small
changes in a large background
so I Scott microscopy stands for
interferometrics cut 3 microscopy so in
this technique we illuminate a sample
with a coherent light source and the
image is generated by the interference
between the illumination that is
reflected by the glass sample interface
and all the back scattered components of
the light by the sample that we're
trying to observe so of course in the
sample everything that has a refractive
index is different than this running
medium will generate a scattering signal
so in a way this is not the same as
doing fluorescence microscopy of course
because we lose the specificity inherent
to fluorescent microscopy but what we
gain is in terms of uh signal signal to
noise ratio and the signal generation
because we are not limited by factors
such as photo bleaching or blinking or
other photophysics inherent to
fluorescence microscopy we can really
accelerate the writer which we collect
data and that is for example a great
advantage in a single particle tracking
the signal is proportional to the
scattering cross-action and the
scattering cross-section of an object is
of course proportional to its mass
especially in the case for example of
proteins has been applications in which
icecato microscopy has been used to
measure the mass of objects in inside
Solutions or in living or in modern
samples
for example and other similar
experiments then now so many
applications it's really hard to keep
track of all of them it's very evil
rapidly evolving field
mass photometry is a
you know it's an implementation of ice
cap
um you know at the end of the day
they're very similar in the sense that
you shine light on the samples and look
at the light that comes back
uh that's also very similar to you know
reflection microscopy that's been around
for 50 years you shine light on Sample
you look at the light comes back
and it's and it's really in the details
of how you illuminate
and how you detect whether it's small
differences right
um the way I look at it is that is
really all about what you're trying to
measure
right
um you know
a slightly more established example
would be you know if you think about
single molecule fluorescence microscopy
it's been around for a long time and
people have known for a long time that
you can look at single molecules and you
can localize them at very high Precision
right
um
but then it was the implementation of
that through switching
fluorescence that kind of got you to
super resolution microscopy right so in
a way super resolution or at least uh
photo activation based super resolution
microscopy you know is is an
implementation of single molecule
localization
and in the same way you know
mass photometry is a
is an implementation of ice scad myscan
is an implementation that's reflection
microscope with respect to microscope as
an implementation of face content blah
blah blah I tend to think about it but
what do you what are you after right an
iscad
um
you know it's really very good you know
and has been most you know predominantly
used in the context of single particle
tracking
so the idea that because you're really
good at detecting
small scatterers
and they don't bleach and you don't
really have power limitations
um you know you can achieve very high uh
frame rates and still maintain very high
uh localization procedures you can do
really good tracking 2D and 3D there's
lots of examples are less to use
um there's some you know very exciting
recent work that people use it to
uh you know study study refractive index
and properties of small particles in
solution
and Mass photometry
is really all about
um
pushing both the sensitivity but also in
particular the Precision
of individual measurements
um and where it becomes really useful is
you know if I can tell the difference
between one protein and two proteins
right all the difference between a 50
kilobolton protein and 100 kilogy
protein
so between different masses we don't
really care so much about tracking
aspect
or the localization Precision it's all
about
um making a very precise measurement on
you know brief events or individual
individual biomolecules
and then use that in order to understand
how you know protein complexes assemble
our proteins interact or you know
kind of you know this General kind of
concept of of what's Happening a lot
in in nature which is that function is
fundamentally connected to proteins
coming together and for biomolecules
coming together and falling apart
in our research we are of course
interested in the favorable
characteristic of voice cut microscopy
for a single particle tracking we have
this large pattern scattering tags
attached to lipids and they diffuse on
cellular membranes or on Modern lipid
membranes we are able to track their
position down down to the millisecond
and Below millisecond
acquisition times and so in that way we
can really get into the finite details
on the movement of these molecules on
the cellular membranes and as more
applications emerge and more
collaborators approach our Labs we hope
to be able to make a connection between
the Dynamics of these molecules on the
living cell membrane and their
physiological function and how the
Dynamics and not just the chemical
properties of these molecules
I haven't have a role into the
physiological functions of diverse cell
lines uh takeover right first step in
the infection is the virus binds to the
cell and how does the virus bind to the
cell well there's a surface protein on
the virus which is a spike and then
there is a
um an enzyme on the on the surface of
the cell called H2 and
they bind strongly by our spines and
then you get endocytosis
so one of the ways to try and develop
drugs is to Target
that interface right
so how do you do that
well one way to do it is to say well if
I if I have the virus
if I find something that binds more
strongly
to the surface broken on the virus then
the cellular receptor then the virus
won't bind to the cell and if the virus
doesn't want to sell I don't get sick
job done right
but in order to do that what you need is
you need methods
that allow you to screen these
interactions to quantify them accurately
to understand the Dynamics thereof and
yes ultimately you have to run an essay
where you check the infectivity right
but when you start you you start with
trying to find candidates that really
disrupt
the interaction
and you know that that's where I really
see
uh unique
you know a unique Niche for Mass
Optometry because it's quick it's easy
and it gives you that key information
right
did this happen or did it not happen
right and that's that's that's a lot of
the time what you care about
foreign
microscopy is that it's really a very
simple technique to implement in a lab
with a certain Optical know-how so it's
basically like one could see it as a
wide field microscope in which coherent
light is uh is used instead of normal
illumination so it's really not that
difficult to implement then of course
there's some other aspects that make it
more complicated like for example the
implementation of beam scanning or of
devices to improve the signal to noise
Ratio or even the resolution of this
technique but it's really quite simple
and for its Simplicity it really
delivers a lot because if we compare it
to other techniques that rely on simple
scattering say for example dark field
microscopy it's it's very uh it's a
trivial mathematical demonstration to
show the ice cut microscopy as an
advantage in terms of the signal to
noise ratio and that is in my opinion
what makes it very very valuable because
but the semi illumination rights at the
same illumination energy we really can
get more out of our signal and we really
can get more details the challenge of
course is that as I was saying
everything in the sample that has a
different refractive index than the
surrounding environment will generate
signal and so we lose the specificity of
techniques like fluorescence microscopy
and especially Turf comes to mind or a
high low microscopy but it really is
quite simple to implement in the same
setup
uh ice cut microscopy and fluorescence
microscopy at least in principle there
have been quite a few demonstrations uh
here and there in literature and so it's
it's really it's really a way to get the
best of both worlds I frame rate and
specificity if one can combine ice cut
microscopy and fluorescence in the same
sample
so really that is the biggest challenge
that has been circumvented by using a
very clean looking samples for example
when one wants to study for example
aggregation of proteins it's really
quite easy to make a very clean solution
but then when one wants to explore the
living matter then it becomes
challenging and that's why we need to
use a large scattering tags for example
like golden like functionalized gold
nanoparticles all these challenges
really are not enough sort of to
dissuade us from using ice cut
microscope because it has shown its
usefulness already and we hope to get
even more out of it in the future
one of the issues that
you know that we're facing is that
one of the key components in in these
microscopes are the other detectors
right
you have to actually detect your Photon
somewhere and you'd have to make images
and because because in these
interferometric techniques you're always
detecting your scattered light together
with background light
if your scattering is very weak that
means you have to really put a lot of
light on which means you have a lot of
background light
and you're trying to detect a small
change on top of a huge background
what everyone else in the world is
trying to do
is to detect a tiny signal on top of
zero background
that is almost the opposite Challenge
from a from a from a detector
perspective I scan unfortunately an MP
and you know most of these
interferometric techniques they want the
opposite
uh so that's one challenge now there's
many others
uh turns out also light sources are not
not ideal
people want really good lasers a nice
cat you want really bad lasers
because good lasers
have long coherence lengths which means
everything interferes with everything
but you only want a little bit of
interference
so you want bad lasers but nobody wants
that lasers not from us
um
and then finally the signals are just
really incredibly small
so I mean in a you know a
state-of-the-art mathematometry
measurement
um
requires sample drift of less than an
angstrom
so you have a micro microscopic piece of
glass and it moves you know the size of
a hydrogen atom your measurement is
ruined
uh so you know it's stabilization
Environmental Protection all of that
kind of stuff becomes incredibly
important
when we want to really accelerate our
our acquisition frame rate we really
need a sensor that is capable of doing
that and unfortunately these don't come
easily available and there are many
technical challenges to having a sensor
that can really achieve this tons of
kilohertz frame lights that have already
been achieved in other techniques but
iscat could give us an edge because of
the increased signal to noise ratio and
the increased signal quality that we can
get out of it so of course for single
particle tracking the dream would be to
have a very fast camera not necessarily
the best in terms of quantum efficiency
because or noise levels because it
really what we're really after is the
detection but of course a lower noise
would mean that we can really push it
and really have at the cleanest signal
possible sometimes what is used is the
industrial cameras so not really come
camera spot for microscopy and those are
at the disadvantage of having a usually
very high noise threshold
but reaching very fast frame rates so
usually we need to go for these cameras
and of course if the as it is the case
with the kinetics that comes to mind we
could really achieve this very fast
frame rates with the very low noise
levels and that would really make all
the difference in in terms of image
quality at the end of the day
so other characteristics that are camera
for ice that could have a really
dependent on the application that we
need for example other applications
don't really require these fast frame
rates
and and of course Quantum efficiency is
not really an issue for ascotic
microscopy being that we can just
increase the number of photons but
sometimes you have very photosensitive
samples so you are really Limited in the
in terms of the light intensity that can
be sent to the sample without risking it
and also the noise levels can be quite
important so having a low noise
threshold could be quite important for
application in which for example Mass
estimation is important and the
fluorescence will the figure of Merit
usually is
somewhere you know somewhat a
combination between readout speed and
read noise
in our case
there's really only one figure of Merit
which is the total number of
photoelectrons you can detect
per second
so the larger that number
the better because that means
that I can detect more light the more
light I detect the smaller my shock
noise essentially my the noise I can't
avoid
and the smaller signal I can see
um
so the cameras that we've been using are
CMOS cameras mostly
a small number of pixels
but with with fast
um
with fast readout
and ideally relatively large pixels
because the bigger the pixels the more
electrons you can store
the more electrons you can store the
more light you have and so on we want to
record data
at several hundred Hertz if not
kilohertz
and so if you're recording data that at
that rate with most cameras
uh you have to reduce the field of view
you know so you take a strip
and that that goes faster yeah
really there have been already a lot of
applications that have the that have
been really quite exciting for example
there is a sister technique of
isothermicroscopy that is uh gaining
some traction I think it needs to be
applied more that would be cobram so
coher they it's called coherent byte
field Imaging
is in Cobra which is really ice cut but
operated in transmission which operates
on a similar on a similar concept for
image generation and that would be
really great to apply to more live
samples especially in the fields of a
single particle tracking and being guys
got and covering of course so sensitive
to small changes in mass and small
changes in refractive index I think it'd
be I I think it'll be a really powerful
tool for biology I mean as it is it has
already been applied for the deduction
of
bonding new viral particles from cells
and the mechanism of infections or the
insertion of viral particles inside
cells Forum yeah for infection and I
think these are really very exciting
directions in which icecat could go in
the future because it will really give
us a more comprehensive view of the
Dynamics of the cell and that is really
what I'm after this is really something
close to my passions so it'll be really
exciting to see it more in the future
I've seen recent applications in which
dynamics of aggregation of proteins on
on model lipid membranes have been
observed and that is really something
that really caught my interest because
if we could only manage to improve on
the technique somehow on the optical
side and then we could
expand the the field of applications and
we could expand the the kind of
phenomena that we could see not only
just with Ascot or ice cutting
combination with other techniques that
would be really really something
fantastic for the community as a whole I
think ice cut microscopy and single
particle tracking in general are very
are amazing applications of modern
modern microscopy techniques I think in
general there's a
and this is not something that I'm uh
I'm contesting or I'm criticizing there
is always a large interest in imaging
there's always a higher amount of
attention in structural studies in the
studies of how we have snapshots of
samples so for example fixed samples and
we can see the structure the finite
details of Destruction this is really
amazing it's really what we've been
waiting uh super resolution microscope
before all these all these decades but
there needs to be also on an increase in
interest in studies of dynamics of how
things interact with each other because
the living matter is always in evolution
is always moving around and it's always
out of equilibrium and we need to
understand the Dynamics of how things
interplay with each other because single
snapshot can only tell you so much and
this is something that with the ice cut
microscopy but also the development on
new technologies for fluorescence
microscopy recent Evolutions in
technology especially for fluorescence
microscopy can really make us explore
another dimension of the word we live in
which would be the temporal Dimension
which is so far not as explored as the
three special dimensions think about
cryo-em right so crying 15 years ago
not very good resolution
right I mean it was mostly blobs but
blobs were still good for Stuff where we
knew nothing
uh 15 years later you can see hydrogen
atoms
I mean it's amazing and
um
you know a significant contributor to
that are better cameras
right better detecting electrons which
means
that you can reduce the noise
for a given electron flux it's important
to be maximally efficient at detecting
your
your electrons
so you know camera technology
I think you know would have a
substantial impact in making it making
scattering Technologies better
making them more sensitive
I think there is a there's an uptick if
you like of label free
Technologies you know situations where
you can detect quantify characterize
samples without having to label them
and
until recently the general assumption
always was well you can do that but
you're never going to be as sensitive as
you are with fluorescence because the
fluorescence you can do single molecules
well that's really not the case anymore
right so
you know if you take a take a
take an image of single proteins in a
massiveometer
um
they look at least as good
as images of single fluorescent
molecules
which you know 10 years ago is
unthinkable
but your ability to detect the stuff
um
uh without having to use fluorescence is
actually
you know more or less as good as it is
with the lessons of course only when
there's nothing else around fluid like
the vacuum thing right so the thing that
the scattering won't do is it won't
detect a single protein inside a cell
why because
there's all this other stuff around and
how could you tell the difference and
that's where fluorescence is magnificent
right the specificity and the background
rejection amazing
um that's why I think fluorescence also
makes a lot of sense in the scan in the
in the Imaging context
but the scattering is more in the
detection
quantification characterization concept
uh context and and one kind of
it's always a challenge are you like oh
you've got a microscope so you've got to
make some images and like well yes
but not with this right with this it's
much more about
uh
extracting information you know about
about individual objects rather than
Imaging structure or how Stuff moves
around I mean the funny thing is you
know if you look at bioanalytical
techniques
a very very big proportion of them is
label free
right cry again level three
the gel label free spr label free bli
label free
Dynamic light scattering label free ITC
label free they're all label free the
number of fluorescence-based methods in
the
area of characterizing protein structure
function regulation
is actually pretty limited right
um
but there always has been this like
I can do label free and look at the
ensemble
or I can do fluorescence and look at
single molecules
that's my choice I don't I don't have an
alternative but now you can do the label
three stuff you look and look at single
molecules so if you think about how we
understand
how a particular process works or how
particular protein works for instance
um there is always this kind of
structure function relationship right
that's been the kind of you know
Hallmark of modern molecular biology if
you like you know you get the structure
once you see the structure you can see
where everything is and then from that
you can derive the function right and
that's been you know one of the major
drivers of improving our understanding
of protein function in the last 50 years
right and you're at X-rays and then you
had cryo-em and and to some degree now
you have Alpha fold which is a you know
an unbelievable advance
um but in many ways I think that the
next challenge the next Frontier is to
go from you know what a relatively
static pictures
um to
being able to understand quantify
interactions and then ultimately
transition towards Dynamics
many thanks again to our guests
Professor Philip kakura and Dr Francesco
Reyna
now I've heard all about scattering
microscopy techniques and applications
let's hear about the available camera
solutions from Teledyne photometrics for
scattering microscopy from our product
manager Dr Phil Allen over to you Phil
thanks Matt and thanks to the presenters
for their interesting work on label-free
Imaging my name is Phil Allen I'm a
product manager for Teledyne
photometrics and today I want to tell
you a little bit about some of the
cameras we think are ideal for
scattering microscopy
as you heard from the presenters there
are lots of challenges in doing this
label-free approach
there's a very weak sample signal often
there's a very intense background with a
very minor change of signal above that
which results in very low sample
contrast and if you're looking at
protein protein nanoparticle and
membrane or membrane membrane
interactions The Binding might occur on
very short time scales so we can't
integrate for a ton of time and we have
to go quickly so some of the solutions
are we need a high sensitivity camera to
get the best signal to noise possible
what that means is we need a high
Quantum efficiency so that we turn every
Photon we generate and send to the
camera and we make sure it gets turned
into signal we also need to minimize
noise
we need a really high full well capacity
because
light in its own right is noisy because
there's what we call shot noise and if
your signal is only changing by a
fraction of percent you want to lose
that in the photon fluxes you'll see in
low intensity measurements so we need a
High full oil capacity for these Dynamic
processes we also need High frame rates
if your event is happening in
milliseconds or microseconds you might
need to be Imaging at hundreds of
thousands of frames per second
so there are three cameras I want to
tell you about today one is a fairly new
the last two years or so and that's the
kinetics six and a half Micron pixel 95
QE a speed mode with 500 frames per
second large field of view 29
millimeters and coming soon in 2023
frame averaging which we'll discuss in a
second
the prime BSI Express also six and a
half microns pixels 95 frames per second
19 millimeter field of view ideal for
your steam out system and frame
summation on it which I'll explain more
in detail in the next couple minutes and
then lastly our Prime 95b back
illuminated 11 Micron pixel which can go
80 frames a second it comes in models
from 18 to 25 millimeters and the value
here is it has a very high full well
capacity so it can take very bright
signals and you can measure very low
contrast things in those very bright
signals
the full well capacity leads to lots of
dynamic range if you were collecting
signal that approaches that full well
capacity so if we look at the 95b with
its 11 Micron pixel or 121 Square
microns per pixel
the linear full well capacity that
you'll get out of our cameras about 55
000 electrons
so with about a one and a half electron
read noise the dynamic range innate in
that camera is about 35
000 won
the prime BSI and the prime BSI Express
are six and a half Micron pixels so only
about 41 microns pixel area
about a third of that of the Prime 95b
but they have a very large full well
capacity in HDR mode of about 45
000 compared to the difference in Signal
area
leading to a dynamic range of about 28
000 to one and because of that smaller
pixel you get better spatial sampling
and then the modern CMOS these days also
six and a half Micron pixels have only
about 15 000 electrons and therefore
give a dynamic range of about ten
thousand to one
so let's talk about the 95b it's what we
call large pixel Imaging lots of folks
are using this for a high mag 100x
functional magnification
where the 11 Micron pixel does a great
job of sampling the spatial resolution
of high n a oil immersion objectives it
was the first back implemented CMOS
camera
has a huge in my mind 55 000 linear full
well capacity
so it gives you a ton of dynamic range
it's got the 95 QE of the back automated
sensor and with those 11 Micron pixels
it's very efficient at collecting
photons because of the large collection
area and then practically it comes in
1822 and 25 millimeter field of view
models that you can match to your
Optical system of your microscope
so real quick this is just a summary and
again at 55 000 electrons full one can
be working at very high dynamic range
very good signal to noise ratios just
with the default detection on the camera
our Prime BSI and BSI Express provide a
lot more flexibility while still
maintaining a really good full well
capacity the full well capacity in HDR
mode is about 45 000 for these cameras
again it's a six and a half Micron pixel
so it's much better at spatial sampling
at 60x and at 40x high in a oil
immersion objectives it also has a high
sensitivity low noise Mode called CMS
correlated multi-sampling mode which
ends up with about 0.9 to 1.1 electrons
of read noise
and from a flexibility perspective also
uses USB 3.2 10 gigabits per second
communication for data transport
and it's actually been used for some of
these techniques particularly iscat in
the past
but again for these low contrast
interference and direct detection images
the key point for the BSI Express is a
pretty large full well capacity
however that full well capacity of about
000 really may not be enough
for some very low contrast Imaging
approaches
one thing we at photometrics have done
to engineer a couple of approaches to
solve The Limited full well capacity
limited dynamic range of some of the
cameras that's been specified just by
the hardware and the pixel size and
settings so one approach is on frame
summation in our pvcam camera driver you
can Implement if you code your own
software it's something that will be We
Believe addressable using micromanager
in the first half or so of 2023 but
effectively it's doing an add up frames
in between the camera hardware and the
arrival of a summed image on your
computer desktop or your computer
software effectively it works with all
of our cameras
so we could take for example a prime 95b
with 55 000 electron full well capacity
and add up 10 frames in a 32-bit data
type and output a resultant 16-bit image
from those 10 frames A reduced noise of
the square root of the number of frames
it's not limited by the processing power
that's in our cameras it's limited by
the processing power coded into our
pvcam software so effectively increases
the functional full well capacity and in
doing so this is the dynamic range
if you increase functional full well and
dynamic range while maintaining low
signal even if you're having to
accumulate multiple signal sources or
multiple noise sources you're going to
increase the signal noise ratio and in
general that's going to increase by the
square root of the number of frames
you've subbed for example if you've sum
16 frames into a resultant output image
you'd expect four times the signal to
noise ratio and image output has a
negligible impact on camera speed
effectively you wouldn't notice a
difference in frame rate using this
unless you started measuring frame rates
out to the third or fourth decibel
points and the nice part is because
we're now limited by computer hardware
not the fpgas in the cameras we can
actually accumulate up to 2 to the 16th
16-bit images so instead of asking
questions of will my image have enough
SNR are you just can dial in the SNR you
need and again it's available with Cam
versions 3.9 but 13.1 and higher
so just as a quick explanation of what
I've been saying so you could also take
for example our armor with the BSI
Express or the kinetics with its low
noise mode in this particular case we're
talking about the 12-bit CMS modes which
have a saturation point of around a
thousand electrons a full well capacity
which is not very large but if you want
to sum so we get a functional full well
capacity of 16 000 the signal to noise
ratio in the output image is going to be
four times greater than any one input
image
and again we can up accumulate up to 2
to the 16th frames and as long as you've
avoided saturation all the data is valid
and good also because this is pvcam this
is our driver software you you can code
to easily switch between a raw output
and some data output and as the last
bullet point says
functionally processing itself has no
effect on camera speed obviously
accumulating multiple frames of X time
is going to have n times x output to
Output image
so we've also done this on the BSI
Express in Hardware I was requested by a
particular industrial customer the prime
BSI can sum up to 128 frames in camera
and then output a single summed image
it's a great solution for working in the
low full well capacity CMS mode which
each frame would saturated about 1100 or
1200 electrons and it that basically
leads to an increase in full wealth
capacity and signal to noise ratio in
the same way we've talked about for
summing on the host computer with
pubicam
we're also intending to do this for
another customer but we'll make it
available to all on the kinetics and
this will actually be not frame
summation but frame averaging and in
this case we will be doing in camera
accumulation in 32-bit mode so we could
accumulate very bright signals in 16-bit
mode and then average many frames and
give a very high intensity very
functional low noise output image
because we run the kinetics so quickly
compared to our competition on other
platforms the functional full well
capacity of the kinetics is much lower
than the other Prime cameras but on we
trade that off again for speeds up to
just under 500 frames per second in the
camera
so with the kinetics you can either use
frame summation and or starting in the
middle or so of 2023 you could use
in-camera frame averaging
as we've mentioned before we're going to
increase SNR reduce noise be able to
detect very low contrast changes that
otherwise would be lost in the noise and
again we'll have more details to share
on this once the feature is fully
implemented in the coming year
so just as a quick reminder of the
kinetics in my mind is one of the most
flexible cameras out there for science
it has 16-bit dynamic range mode 83
frames a second and as a reminder that's
83 frames at 10 megapixels each
stretching out 3200 by 3200 six and a
half Micron pixels but it only has a
full well capacity of 15 000 versus our
BSI and BSI Express which is the same
pixel size of a functional full wall
capacity of around 45
000. it has the sensitivity mode 88
frames a second
it has speed mode just shy of 500 frames
a second and it has very low read noise
sub Electro mode
so just as a reminder for those of you
aren't aware about the general features
of the kinetics
if you wanted to take a standard CMOS
camera and quick go 100 frames a second
and ask it to go 500 frames a second
you'd have to region down to about
one-fifth of the area or about 400 rows
use the kinetics you can get the full
frame at 500 frames a second that's
effective and 11 times larger area
if you're looking for field of view the
sensor is the biggest one available in
the scientific market so it's 2.4 times
larger than typical CMOS 6.5 times
larger than the emccd those are area
numbers and even at 16-bit HDR kind of
data you've got much faster throughput
and coverage than any other camera out
there so you capture everything your
microscope can put out and as
illustration of this if this was a
typical emccd or CCD image for those of
you predate CMOS
here's a standard CMOS
here's our kinetics 22 in green and then
the full field of view capture with the
kinetics shown in the background
so quick summary 0.7 electron read noise
95 QE lots of pixels to make 10
megapixel frames six and a half Micron
pixels which work well for the
microscopy world with to high
magnification High n a objectives
incredible throughput in terms of speed
and data biggest sensor area
we also for those of you who don't have
Optical systems that can cover that much
have our kinetics 22 has the same frame
times as the kinetics same specs but is
a region down to 2400 by 2400 pixels
so it matches the maximum area that a
steam out can output
so with that I'm going to hand it back
to Matt thank you for your time
thanks to Phil for taking us through the
prime and kinetic CMOS families as well
as our frame summation and averaging
capabilities
we also have a customer story from
Professor Christian Eglin who is using
the prime BSI Express for a combination
of icecat and turf microscopy in order
to observe molecule diffusion on live
cell membranes
this group required a flexible camera
that could integrate into their
specialized software and have made great
use of the Prime BSI Express as CMOS
the prime BSI Express is fast and
sensitive and has been an ideal solution
for this application
able to capture the entire relevant
field of view or to create a small
region of interest in order to operate
an extreme high speeds
the camera was integrated into the
required m-switch software using our
provided python wrapper and our great
compatibility with third-party imaging
software and as mentioned the prime BSI
Express gave us flexibility for both
Turf and icecat at a high speed and
across a large area without difficulty
here we can see an image from this
experiment using iscat with an insert as
well showing the high sample contrast
against a large Imaging background
picked how easily thanks to the
sensitivity and large full well of the
Prime BSI Express
in summary
scattering microscopy approaches provide
a label-free alternative to fluorescence
microscopy with nanoscale 3D spatial
resolution and microscale temporal
resolution
these techniques require cameras that
can detect a weak signal against a large
Imaging background needing both High
sensitivity high speed and a large full
well capacity
the range of modern CMOS cameras at
teledome photometrics are a great fit
such as the kinetics and Prime families
but all of our cameras have frame
summation capabilities through our pvcam
driver in order to increase both the
full well and your Imaging signal to
noise ratio
that's everything from our webinar today
many thanks for your attention if you'd
like to find out more please contact us
via our website at www.photometrics.com
and I hope you have a great rest of your
day thanks again for listening
and thank you for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of this webinar with Dr
Matthew Jose Dunn if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
Dr Jose Dunn looks like we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
a label that is strong scatter and track
the proteins of interest is that correct
yeah so while the sketching techniques
themselves are inherently label free as
in
you don't need a label to get the
contrast necessary to receive a signal
or do the Imaging
it does
mean that you can also get particles
that scatter very strongly and use them
as labels if you wish to do so this
would have some downsides with regards
to localization and you know making sure
you wash them off after labeling the
kind of things you'd encounter
fluorescence labels but while these
images and techniques can be label free
there's the option to use highly
scattering particles as labels if
necessary depending on your application
thank you so much
now at current state of art what camera
would the presenters recommend if
building in iscat microscope from
scratch
um kinetics or something cheaper like a
machine vision camera
so
in the webinar we outlined the kinetics
and the two prime cameras the 95b and
the BSI Express these are great for
scattering because what you want is you
want a full
oh well basically and you can get a lot
of cameras that can operate at a high
speed or have a low read noise and we
offer these cameras too but the unique
capability that often isn't focused on
in other applications but is here is the
full well and our cameras have a larger
full well than similar Solutions and if
the foil isn't large enough you can
still increase that further with the
frame summing capabilities in the pvcam
driver or in the camera's fpga
themselves so the kinetics will offer
frame summing and averaging the BSI
Express also offers summing so we have a
range of flexible solutions for iscap
mainly because of the much larger full
well so you can image the incredibly
you know get as much of signal as you
can from your sample as well as the
background that it's within
thank you so much and I want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in our next audience member
actually put his name Phil Yoon from
synchrolex he says as I see the readout
noise is quite low what is this signal
to noise ratio from the CMOS cameras
yes so the readout noise is very low we
drive this as low as possible it's in
the one electron to sub-electron levels
for the majority of our cameras
and so this means that when you have a
high signal collection and a low noise
level you get a great signature noise
ratio it does depend on
the signal that you're receiving
so the signature noise ratio largely
depends on what signal you're getting in
the first place if you're operating in a
very low light area then read noise is
all the more important you'll be read
noise Limited but in general
even if you're operating with a handful
of photons the cameras have a
significant signal to noise ratio so we
don't have a stated value for any of
these because it depends on your
application and it's quite subjective
but I've yet to see any applications
where you know you're getting flooded
out by noise basically
and Dr kozetan is does the the camera
operate at room temperature what is the
operating temperature
so these cameras are all equipped with
forced air cooling so we aim for a
temperature around
-15 to -25
this means that you can bypass any
effects of dark current not that dark
current is very significant in this
application because you're not typically
Imaging or exposing for a very long time
so the camera will operate at room
temperature it'll operate at any
temperatures you know in even very hot
rooms up to 30 and 40 degrees if we're
talking about the temperature of the
environment you're operating in but the
camera itself will be aiming for
Sub-Zero temperatures because of the
cooling
thank you so much our next question what
is the relationship between mass and
Optical
polarizability of a particle or protein
and this is a two-part question the
scattering cross section should be
proportional to the polarizability which
is dominated by the mobility of the
outer shell electrons not so much on the
total number of electrons or the mass of
the particles
so
I would definitely have to consult
someone like Philip kakura again for
this because I'm not an expert when it
comes to the scattering aspect of
scattering microscopy but in general my
understanding is that the mass is
proportional to the scattering as for
the polarizability I'm not entirely sure
my basic
go to here is the fact that you can
detect these extremely small particles
even down to the atomic level
while they're in a very large Imaging
background so I'm assuming the
polarizability of your sample may affect
the scattering but you've we've been
able to see things that are less
are less able to scatter light and
therefore if your sample is able to tune
its polarizability you will still be
able to see quite a lot of it and
hopefully you'll be able to get some
contrast
thank you so much and again I want to
thank our audience these are great
questions we have time for a couple more
um the next question I understand the
benefit of frame summation for
increasing full well capacity but I'm
curious whether it would have any
benefit for low light samples under
conditions where pixels are not
saturated is there any benefit to let's
say summing 10x 10 ms exposures compared
to taking a single 100 Ms Exposure My
intuition is that summation would be
worse under such conditions because read
noise would be additive but curious to
hear your thoughts
what do you think
yeah so great question
as it stands the application of frame
summing in this iteration is mainly for
the additional full well capacity
if you're in a low light regime
that's another application that our
cameras are designed towards and we have
cameras like the kinetics that can go
extremely fast in order to go fast you
need very short exposure times often in
the millisecond or sub millisecond level
so you need the camera's ability to
detect sufficient sample with a very
short exposure time
so you're correct that summing 10 10
millisecond exposures would probably not
be as good as taking a single 100
millisecond exposure because the read
noise will add up to a rate below the
signal but the camera will be capable of
taking images at around 10 milliseconds
or below regardless
and then if you're struggling to achieve
the right signal to noise ratio at a
really short exposure your options are
going to be to increase the light level
or to try and change your fluorophore in
this regard frame summation is mainly
here to bulk out the full wall capacity
and make sure you can capture your very
small signal a large background so for
fluorescence Imaging it's got different
applications
Dr Jose definitely have time for one
more question can label-free scattering
used for 3D imaging and if yes how can
it provide view of different angles
great question uh yes to my
understanding label-free Imaging can be
used for 3D
this is due to the interactions of the
particle with the background quite a lot
of these applications see the background
as a nuisance I want you to see the
sample and not any of the background and
can smooth this out with algorithms but
the background itself does give
information as to where the particle is
likely to be moving in 3D Space by how
it's interacting with the background so
I don't know how you can provide a view
of different angles this would be more
something like light field microscopy
where you can see your sample in all the
different angles and you can get the
direction and velocity with scattering
microscopy I do know you have the
capability to see it in 3D but I'm not
sure if you're able to view it from
different angles just an appreciation of
where it is in the Z plane for example
well I want to thank you and I want to
thank all the presenters today for their
presentation and Dr Cozy done would you
like to provide any final comments for
our audience before we go
yeah I'd like to thank the speakers
again Dr Philip kakur and Dr Francesca
Reina at photometrics we focus a lot on
fluorescence low light microscopy but
it's great to also see these additional
applications in other fields like
scattering microscopy as well and if I
haven't been able to answer any of your
questions or if you have
extra things you want to know about
either the products or the application
itself we have lots of information on
our website which is
www.photometrics.com so there we have
information on our products but also
applications like scattering microscopy
and Ice get as well so feel free to come
along and if I haven't answered your
questions please feel free to email me
as well
I want to thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
and I'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Teledyne photometrics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go I want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand Labyrinth will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone bye-bye
thanks very much